und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend wir wissen ja ende der woche gibt
es keine fünf tage oster ruhe
die frage ist was kommt stattdessen von
der marathonsitzung der erschöpften
regierungschefinnen und chefs ist ja
fast nichts übrig und nix ist keine
option wenn die sache so rasant in die
falsche richtung läuft wie zurzeit
seit anfang märz ist das lagebild für
deutschland dramatisch schlechter
geworden die sonntags zahlen des robert
koch instituts zeigen mehr als 17.000
109 infektionen binnen 24 stunden 3443
mehr als vergangenen sonntag das
geschehen beschleunigt sich also weiter
der bundesweite incidents wert steigt
auf knapp 130 gegensteuern wird mit
jedem tag der vergeht immer schwieriger
ministerpräsident kretschmann denkt
darüber nach die gerade erst
gescheiterten ministerpräsidentinnen neu
zusammenzurufen
jetzt sollte man doch lieber erst mal
ernst machen mit der notbremse bremst
der kollege söder
ansonsten ist heute kaum etwas geschehen
was der rede in dieser beziehung wert
wäre
beginnen wir mit einem gegenmittel
leider nicht gegen cobit 19 aber gegen
den aberglauben dass das schlimmste
vorbei sei weil ja die sehr alten und
schwachen bald durch geimpft sein und
junge leute die es immer öfter erwischt
die krankheit gut wegstecken falsch
berichtet torge bode
noch vor einem jahr hatte leer
basketball gespielt auf höchstem niveau
jugendbundesliga nationalmannschaft mit
17 jahren
vor genau einem jahr im märz steckt sich
lehr mit dem corona virus an
heute schafft sie keine drei minuten auf
dem laufband die akute corona erkrankung
verlief wie eine starke grippe aber nach
einer woche waren diese symptome weg die
richtigen probleme fingen erst ein paar
wochen später an muskelschmerzen
geschmacks und geruchs verlust vor allem
aber permanente erschöpfung
ich kann das einfach also ich hab das
körperlich nicht mein körper erschöpft
das passt sehr gut zu den beschwerden
die eben doch viele angeben die lange
noch beeinträchtigt sind nach einer
virusinfektion und das was bei vielen im
vordergrund steht ist eben wirklich die
eingeschränkte belastbarkeit dass sie
den alltag überhaupt nicht mehr so
ausführen können dass sie schon
beitragsbelastungen an die grenzen ihrer
fitness kommen dass erwachsene nach
einer corona erkrankung unter umständen
mit spätfolgen zu kämpfen haben weiß man
mittlerweile longo wird nennt man dieses
syndrom
doch immer häufiger klagen auch kinder
und jugendliche über beschwerden wochen
und monate nach der eigentlichen
erkrankung selbst wenn diese ganz und
gar symptomfrei war wie bei ella
sie ist zehn und hatte ihre kleine
schwester carla angesteckt erst acht
wochen nach der infektion geht es beiden
plötzlich schlecht ständig wird ihnen
schwarz vor augen und schwindelig
sie hatte erster phase mit viel schöne
danach hatte sie eine phase wird viel
schwinde und die kinderärztin hat dann
mehr oder weniger in zusammenhang
gestellt und uns dann hier nach bochum
geschickt ein bisschen mehr
herauszufinden ob es einen zusammenhang
da sein kann
erste studien in england und italien
zeigen dass bei bis zu 15 prozent der
infizierten kinder teils gravierende
spätfolgen auftreten können hierzulande
fängt man erst an daten zu erheben
außerdem stellt sich die frage ob die
körperlichen beschwerden jeweils auf die
virusinfektion zurückzuführen sind oder
aber auf eine erhöhte psychische
belastung durch andauerndes shutdowns
wir müssen auch ernst nehmen dass kinder
in dieser pandemie vielleicht eine der
bevölkerungsgruppen ist die am stärksten
leitet die am stärksten von den
auswirkungen betroffen ist und dass
diese auswirkungen lange nachwirken
werden und dass wir uns den wie gesagt
als gesellschaft und als politik aber
auch jeder einzelne stellen müssen
lea ist gerade im abiturstress und sie
hat zukunftsangst was wenn die
beschwerden bleiben auf einige fragen
hat die medizin antworten leer bekommt
für ihre kurzatmigkeit eine atemtherapie
ihre neurologischen probleme bleiben
aber derzeit ein rätsel
die forschung zu longo wird gerade bei
kindern steht noch ganz am anfang
[Musik]
schicksale in deutschland um an
wenigstens hoffnung haben darf eine
kompetente behandlung nach dem stand der
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse zu
bekommen
alles was wir hier erleben und berichten
ist aber teil einer ehrt umspannenden
solche corona stößt uns gerade wieder
mal mit aller härte darauf dass es nur
eine menschheit gibt und nur eine erde
wie beim menschen gemachten klimawandel
niemand handelt mehr für sich allein
fatale fehler an einem ort wirken global
brasilien wo eine wissenschafts
feindliche regierung mit dem regenwald
einen schatz der menschheit abfackeln
lässt fördert gerade auch noch durch
nichtstun die verbreitung einer extrem
gefährlichen corona variante 1 die
taucht mittlerweile auch schon in
deutschland auf in spuren die das virus
aus johann vor 14 monaten auch erstmal
in spuren in brasilien selbst ist die
lage aber zunehmend außer kontrolle
berichtet christoph rückgrat der
shutdown als notbremse in rio steht das
öffentliche leben wieder weitgehend
still
doch viele bringt das in andere nöte
wovon sollen sie leben hunderte
demonstrieren gegen eine lage aus der es
kurzfristig keinen ausweg gibt
wir brauchen eine impfung und nicht das
alles geschlossen wird wie sollen wir so
geld verdienen was sollen wir essen wir
müssen arbeiten die situation
verschlimmert sich in einem nie
dagewesenen tempo bin nur zweieinhalb
monaten erhöhte sich die zahl der toten
von 200.000 auf 300.000 fast im ganzen
land befindet sich das gesundheitswesen
im zusammenbruch tausende warten auf
freie betten und sterben wir erleben
gerade das was wir den perfekten sturm
wir haben es mit virusvarianten zu tun
die die verbreitung verstärkt dazu kommt
dass immer weniger menschen masken
tragen und immer mehr unterwegs
auffällig gestiegen ist die zahl der
jüngeren patienten im verdacht steht die
erstmals am amazonas aufgetretene virus
variante p1 die ansteckender ist und
auch genesene erneut befallen kann
manche ärzte sprechen schon von einer
neuen krankheit die korona an
gefährlichkeit übertrifft was wir
beobachten sind jüngere patienten in die
krankenhäuser kommen menschen deren
zustand sich schneller verschlechtert
das heißt es scheint wirklich eine
variante zu sein die außer des größeren
ansteckung potenzials auch das potenzial
hat eine schwere krankheit auszulösen
vor allem unter jungen während die
impfkampagne mangels impfstoff immer
wieder ins stocken gerät hat präsident
ball szenario noch immer kein fundiertes
konzept vorgelegt gegen die pandemie der
von anfang an verharmlost hat shutdown
maßnahmen lehnt er ab stattdessen
verhöhnt er seine kritiker wobei er
kürzlich für entsetzen sorgte als er
dabei eine an corona leidende person
limitiert
statt wissenschaft zu akzeptieren
propagiert szenario unwirksame oder
umstrittene medikamente für eine
angebliche frühbehandlung was laut
ärzten menschenleben gefährdet weil
erkrankte sich auf die vermeintliche
wirkung verlassen und viel zu spät zum
arzt gehen wenn sie dann zu uns ins
krankenhaus kommen ist ihr verlauf schon
weit fortgeschritten
manchmal können wir praktisch nichts
mehr tun außer sie zu intubieren
wissenschaftler warnen dass die
offensichtliche unwilligkeit der
regierung das virus ernsthaft zu
bekämpfen zu einer weltweiten gefahr
werden könnte brasilien wird zu einer
globalen bedrohung
wegen des schlechten umgangs des
präsidenten mit der pandemie haben wir
hier perfekte bedingungen für die
entstehung einer virusvariante die
resistent gegen die impfungen ist das
kann dazu führen dass die pandemie in
all den ländern wo sie schon unter
kontrolle war wieder von vorne losgeht
aktivisten einige wissenschaftler und
ärzte fordern internationalen druck auf
brasilien oder wenigstens hilfe beim
impfen
deutschland hat sich bereit erklärt
einen beitrag zu leisten
zunächst mit beatmungsgeräten wie die
bundeswehr am wochenende nach manaus
geflogen hat nachrichten von gundula
gause die zunehmende gewalt des militärs
in myanmar wird weltweit scharf
kritisiert gestern waren bei protesten
gegen die militärjunta mehr als 100
menschen getötet worden darunter kinder
das ist die höchste opferzahl an einem
tag seit dem putsch am ersten februar
trotz der gefahr gab es in ganz mehr
nach wieder demonstrationen und
trauerzüge für die getöteten
ein un sonderberichterstatter
bezeichnete das vorgehen der
sicherheitskräfte als massenmord die
welt müsse eingreifen auch militärchefs
aus zwölf staaten verurteilten die
gewalt in ihren
noch immer blockiert der riesige
frachter gegen den suezkanal die
eingesetzten spezialunternehmen hoffen
mit weiteren schleppern nach einer
erwarteten frühjahrs flut das 400 meter
lange schiff freizubekommen
der nächste schritt wäre eine teil
entladung die vorbereitungen dazu hat
ägyptens präsident als sie sie
angeordnet denn der druck auf die
verantwortlichen wächst rund 370 schiffe
warten auf durchfahrt
entsprechend groß sind die
wirtschaftlichen schäden eine halbierung
des fleischkonsums hat das
umweltbundesamt gefordert dessen
präsident sagte der funke mediengruppe
die massentierhaltung müsse reduziert
und damit hohe stickstoffeinträge in
boden und wasser gesenkt werden es tue
gesundheit und umwelt gut weniger aber
qualitativ besseres fleisch zu essen im
ruhrgebiet ist ein weiteres kapitel
steinkohle geschichte zu ende gegangen
ein stillgelegtes kohlekraftwerk in
lünen wurde gesprengt zuerst stürzte wie
geplant der 250 meter hohe schornstein
zusammen danach kesselhaus und kühlten
420 kilogramm sprengstoff in 2100
bohrlöchern liegt das kraftwerk in staub
und trümmer auf dem industriegelände
soll ein neues gewerbegebiet entstehen
christen in aller welt haben am heutigen
palmsonntag die karwoche eröffnet
überschattet von einem
selbstmordanschlag auf eine katholische
kirche in indonesien bei dem 20 menschen
verletzt wurden
pabst franziskus rief zu gebeten für die
opfer auf wegen corona fiel die
traditionelle messe auf dem petersplatz
aus vor wenigen gläubigen im petersdom
erklärte der papst die müdigkeit durch
corona werde spürbar durch die pandemie
seien viele menschen in schwierigkeiten
franziskus rief zu mitgefühl und nähe
auf romano kutter causa finita wenn rom
entschieden hat ist die sache
abgeschlossen das war ein eiserner
grundsatz in der katholischen kirche
aber der scheint nicht mehr so ganz zu
gelten
mitte des monats schlug ein knallharter
brief aus rom
wenn die krisengeschüttelte deutsche
kirche nicht wegen sexueller gewalt
gegen kinder nicht zum verhalten des
kölner kardinals woelki sondern zu einem
thema bei dem sich gerade ein
versöhnlicher weg angebahnt hatte ein
segen bibel voller anerkennung mehr
nicht für homosexuelle paare ein segen
wie sie priester und bischöfe für 100
verschiedene dinge geben können gerne
auch für so banale wie motorräder tiere
und bergsteiger ausrüstung aber
homosexuellen paaren soll das verwehrt
bleiben entschied die oberste glaubens
behörde des vatikan
die katholische kirche in deutschland
muss jetzt entscheiden ob sie sich das
gefallen lässt und eine welle des
widerstands baut sich auf ulrike rödl
berichtet 18 jahre ist es her dass
thomas pöschl und sein mann in dieser
frankfurter kirche gesegnet wurden in
kleinem kreis mit verwandten und
freunden
die feier fand inoffiziell stadt den
offiziell dürfen homosexuelle paare in
der katholischen kirche den segen nicht
erhalten
das hat uns und aber auch vor allem
unseren verwandten unseren eltern
unseren geschwistern bedeutet dass wir
von der katholischen kirche genauso
angenommen sind wie alle anderen vor
zwei wochen hatte der vatikan sein nein
zur segnung homosexueller paare noch
einmal bekräftigt es entspreche nicht
dem plan gottes so die begründung in der
stellungnahme verweist die
glaubenskongregation auf ihre generelle
haltung gegenüber homosexuellen
nach der lehre der kirche ist den
männern und frauen mit homosexuellen
tendenzen mit achtung mitleid und takt
zu begegnen
die stellungnahme aus rom löst in vielen
katholischen gemeinden einen sturm der
entrüstung aus auch hier in hamm das
verbot das rom ist für die gemeinde
anmaßung und diskriminierung im ersten
auch nicht wie vor den kopf gestoßen und
frag mich wie soll ich meinen kindern
erklären warum sie mit mir weiter in
dieser kirche bleiben sollen wir wollen
ja auch den kindern und jugendlichen
eine vielseitige und offene welt zeigen
und keine eingegrenzt hat das wirklich
mich hat's wind gemacht und ich empfinde
das als gottlos bernd münkel bücher ist
pfarrer in der st agnes gemeinde in hamm
und will trotz des verbotes weiter
segnen
eine mutige entscheidung denn er
riskiert suspendiert zu werden gemeinsam
mit einem pfarrer aus würzburg sammeln
sie über 2600 unterschriften von
seelsorge nden und überreichen sie
vertretern der bischofskonferenz und des
synodalen wegs da tut es weh wenn kirche
von oberster stelle ein urteil spricht
mit naturrecht herkommt im grunde immer
noch damit unausgepackt signalisierte
seit menschen zweiter klasse
der protest aus deutschland und anderen
ländern rüttelt an selbstbild der
katholischen kirche und an ihrem
fundament das nein aus rom fügt sich ein
in eine reihe von verboten die gläubigen
nicht mehr hinnehmen wollen
wie zum beispiel das verbot frauen zur
wahl zuzulassen
es könnte sagen kirchenrechtler den
aktuellen reformkurs in deutschland
ausbremsen für den sudan weg bedeutet
dass mindestens drei themen nicht mehr
weiter diskutiert werden sollten nämlich
die frage
aufhebung des pflichtzölibats weihe von
frauen zu priesterinnen und eben eine
pfändung der sexualmoral in allen drei
fällen ein paar franziskus mehr als
deutlich in jüngster vergangenheit
signalisiert dass ich hier keine
veränderungen möchte
damit hat sich das normale weg in diesen
drei themenfeldern komplett erledigt
unter den katholischen bischöfen in
deutschland gibt es viel zuspruch für
die proteste doch einig sind sie sich
nicht zu denen die für das verbot sind
gehören beispielsweise bischof oder
holzer aus regensburg sowie bischof
oster aus passau der in einer
der name schreibt beziehungsformen sind
ausdrucksformen menschlichen handelns
und nicht jedes handeln ist richtig und
gut daher auch nicht jede beziehung
pfarrer münkel bücher aus hamm hat vor
ein paar tagen an seiner kirche die
regenbogenfahne gehisst sie ihn erst auf
dem kirchplatz nun hängt sie dichter am
kreuz
vor elf jahren hat der bischof von essen
franz josef overbeck bei anne will noch
erklärt homosexualität sei wider die
natur von mann und frau und eine sünde
heute fordert er eine wie er sagt
ernsthafte und zutiefst wertschätzende
neubewertungen der homosexualität guten
abend herr bischof was soll das heißen
in den vergangenen jahren vor allen
dingen nach dieser sendung gab es viele
und begegnung gegeben mit homosexuellen
menschen aber auch paaren bei uns in
essen und woanders und durch diese
vielen gespräche aber auch die dann
folgenden reflexionen darauf ist mir
schon deutlich geworden
hier ist ein nächster schritt zu tun das
habe ich getan und das ist jetzt noch
einmal in dem brief den ich an die
vereine unseres bistums essen
geschrieben habe deutlich geworden das
ist ein brief der nicht auf der linie
der glaubenskongregation liegt die hat
offensichtlich den erkenntnisprozess
noch vor sich den sie schon geschafft
haben
mir ist deutlich geworden wenn ich an
die seelsorgerinnen und seelsorger
unsere priester und die anderen die mit
vielen menschen so eben auch mit
homosexuellen paaren die in treuen
verbindlichkeit miteinander leben zu tun
haben mir erzählen hier liegt segen auf
solchen menschen
das ist für mich dann auch
selbstverständlich ist zu sagen ja das
ist so und die glaubenskongregation lebt
noch in der alten welt und muss sich
dann notfalls auch richtigen widerstand
aus deutschland zum beispiel gefallen
lassen es sind ja nicht nur deutsche
stimmen die sagen hier müssen wir andere
schritte nach vorne gehen sondern in der
weltkirche gibt es sie ebenso wir sehen
dass wir hier neu darauf aus sein müssen
zu zeigen wie können wir die eine
weltliche seien in sehr
unterschiedlichen kulturen und in der
kultur in der wir hier in deutschland
leben ergeben sich eben genau im blick
auf partnerschaft auf ehe auf das
miteinander von frau und mann neue
perspektiven die wir so in der tradition
in dieser deutlichkeit noch nicht
gesehen haben nun müssen sie aber leben
leben und führen in angesicht dessen was
da aus roben gekommen ist was machen sie
jetzt sie müssten ja theoretisch
priester die unverdrossen weiter zum
beispiel homosexuelle paare segnen dann
suspendieren kommt das für sie in frage
das kommt für mich nicht in frage wir
sind da schon seit jahren in einen
lebendigen dialog und haben auch mit den
zuständig und verantwortlichen fahrern
sehr sehr offen darüber gesprochen
dabei ist sehr deutlich geworden es gibt
diejenigen unter unseren priestern aber
auch anderen in der seelsorge tätigen
sie sprechen einen segen wenn erbeten
wird als eine form von begleitung
solcher menschen aber deutlich nicht als
eine form von trauung oder eine form von
einer solchen partnerschaft bekundung
wie wir sie da in einer eheschließung
erleben sondern wir zeigen wir sind bei
euch und erleben das als von gott
gesegnet gleichzeitig gibt es auch ganz
viele andere menschen die immer wieder
da
fragen gesegnet zu werden auch das wird
jetzt zur wirklichkeit der seelsorge
das tun wir so gemeinsam und wir gehen
einen guten weg so wie werden sie jetzt
aus einem papst schlau der auf der einen
seite in einem interview gesagt hat er
forderte den staat auf rechtliche rahmen
zu schaffen die es homosexuellen paaren
ermöglichen familie zu leben
auf der anderen seite aber sagt seine
glaubenskongregation das ist noch nicht
mal den segen wert der sonst für
haustiere und für automobile und
sonstwas erteilt wird aber für diese
paare zum beispiel nicht die
vielschichtigkeit der welt in der wir
leben wird auch in dem deutlich fast
parbs franziskus selber tut in seinen
einlassungen gerade auch am anfang
seines pontifikats zum beispiel zu den
fragen der ehe hat der wunderbares wort
dazu geschrieben amoris letizia wird das
deutlich zeigt dass hier die
gewissensfragen eine neue rolle spielen
und dass hier auch die fragen wie leben
wir mit allen menschen zusammen und wie
können wir eine stimme für alle menschen
seien von größerer bedeutung ist und von
der erleben wir gerade unter den
rücksichten die sie beschrieben haben
die spannungs breites katholischen und
ich finde das tröstet mich auch in
meiner aufgabe als bischof immer wieder
dass die alte formel des sowohl-als-auch
und nicht das entweder oder
da von bedeutung ist und wir leben das
sowohl als auch das gilt aber auch ein
sowohl als auch unter deutschen
bischöfen oder sind alle bischöfe in
dieser hinsicht auch ihre ansicht wir
leben das auch in der deutschen kirche
dass das in aller unterschiedlichkeit
wahrgenommen wird und dass die
vorstellungen auch die bewertung sehr
unterschiedlich sind
das gehört dazu und der synodale weg den
wir als kirche in deutschland gerade
gehen zeigt ja dass es dafür formen von
dialog auseinandersetzung aber auch von
echtem und ich hoffe konstruktiven
konflikt gibt und denen müssen wir
eingehen
eingerechnet auch gegenwind aus rom
dankeschön bischof oberbeck bitte schön
herr kleber und wir haben das gespräch
vor einer guten stunde geführt es gibt
noch nachrichten aus dem sport
mehr skiflug weltmeister karl geiger ist
beim weltcup finale im slowenischen
planica mit einem doppelsieg ein
herausragender saisonabschluss gelungen
der oberstdorfer gewann mit weiten von
232 metern vor dem japaner kobayashi und
seinem teamkollegen markus eisenbichler
und damit die kleine kristallkugel im
skiflug-weltcup bereits am freitag hatte
tiger das einzel springen gewonnen
zum abschluss alle guten wünsche der
teams für den bei einem skisprung
verunglückten norweger tonne
heute wurde er aus dem künstlichen koma
geholt
den auftakt der formel 1 saison in
bahrain hat rekord weltmeister lewis
hamilton gewonnen
der mercedes pilot siegte vor
herausforderer max verstappen im red
bull und seinem teamkollegen valtteri
bottas für hamilton ist es der 96 sieg
seiner karriere
sebastian vettel beendete das erste
rennen für erst martin auf dem 15
debütant mit schumacher fuhr auf platz
spanien hat einen schritt in richtung
normalität gewagt und erstmals seit
beginn der korona pandemie ein größeres
test konzert zugelassen
5000 menschen durften in barcelona ein
live konzert besuchen
mit allem was dazugehört gemeinsam
feiern singen und tanzen natürlich unter
strengen schutzmaßnahmen alle zuschauer
mussten zuvor einen schnelltest machen
und maske tragen auch nach dem konzert
werden die besucher 14 tage lang
überwacht und mögliche ansteckungsfälle
dokumentiert sowas schönem aus
sachsen-anhalt aus dem schlossgarten von
merseburg schickt uns andreas weise ein
geschichte über ein gewaltig großes
kunstwerk mit einem noch größeren thema
die zukunft europas
ein werk der künstlerin antoinette die
so wenig einen nachnamen braucht wie zum
beispiel christo so groß ihr werk ist
und so viel liebe und mühe steckt in
kleinsten filigranen details gemalt mit
ganz normalen stiften in ganz
außerordentliche
hinter den türen der orangerie des
schlosses merseburg ein werk 20 meter
breite und sechs meter hoch der altar
der europa focus magnum der leipziger
künstlerin
autonet drei jahre hat sie daran
gearbeitet in prag görlitz wien und hier
in merseburg im zentrum sieben frauen
porträts ihre interpretationen der
europa der frau die dem kontinent seinen
namen gab wächterinnen sollen sie seinem
ewigen kampf zwischen wahrheit und lüge
zwischen dunkelheit und licht ein alter
das ist ja hat auch was mit unseren
europäischen geschichte zu tun dass wir
auf den altären sozusagen immer eine
bebilderung unseres denkens auch hatten
und das ist natürlich nur spirituell
gewesen in der vergangenheit und in der
heutigen zeit in der wir in große
umbrüche geraten
es ist glaube ich wieder notwendig dass
wir einen ort haben an dem wir unsere
rituale üben können kein
überdimensionales ölgemälde auch wenn es
an die werke von goya oder bosch
erinnern soll
alles ist gezeichnet mit mehr als 1.500
blei und buntstiften akribischer
handarbeit antoinette das ist leipziger
schule
vor allem bekannt durch jedoch auch sie
selbst meisterschülerin bernhard heisigs
einem der bildenden künstler der ddr
immer an ihrer seite partner und manager
thomas hampel das künstlerdasein corona
zeiten alles andere als einfach
wir sind ja da im bereich von so knapp
40% umsatzeinbrüchen und das ist schon
dann auch für eine künstlerin schwer so
was zu tun und klar natürlich hat man
als künstlerin immer schwankende
einnahmen das ist ganz klar die sind die
ausschläge sind natürlich immer da aber
wenn sozusagen die basis schon mal
reduziert ist dann fällt es natürlich
doppelt schwer
galerien dicht besucher nur per internet
das hautnahe erlebnis kunst es ist
derzeit kaum möglich auftragsarbeiten
bringen das nötige geld
porträts viele prominente hat sie schon
gemalt gezeichnet modelliert egon bahr
zum beispiel angela merkel wünscht sie
sich wenn deren zeit als kanzlerin
vorbei ist politik in zeiten von
alternativen fakten internet treibt das
ringen zwischen wahrheit und lüge nicht
nur in ihrem werk ich glaube in dieser
welt in der man glaubt dass man wirklich
unendlich viele standpunkte einnehmen
kann muss man darauf zurück geworfen
werden dass es wirklich nur eine
realität und eine wahrhaftigkeit gibt wo
der altar der europa seinen endgültigen
platz finden wird ist noch offen
in merseburg oder anderswo ist zum
herbst bleiben er und intranet auf jeden
fall erstmal hier
tja wo sollten sie auch hin
der ausblick in die kommende woche kommt
von simone friedrich
[Musik]
nach dem tod des afroamerikaners george
floyd im us-bundesstaat minnesota im
vergangenen mai beginnt am montag das
hauptverfahren
angeklagt ist ein inzwischen entlassener
weißer polizist ihm drohen bis zu 40
jahre haft
er hatte floyd zu boden gedrückt obwohl
der immer wieder sagte er könne nicht
atmen
wer mit dem flugzeug nach deutschland
einreist muss ab 0 uhr am dienstag einen
negativen corona test vorliegen der
höchstens 48 stunden alt ist
urlauber die positiv getestet sind
müssen im urlaubsland in quarantäne
die kosten für test und quarantäne
tragen sie selbst bayern startet am
donnerstag als erstes bundesland die
korona impfungen bei den hausärzten in
der woche nach ostern so der bund länder
beschluss sollen die hausärzte in ganz
deutschland in die impfkampagne
einsteigen vorerst mit 20.000 pro woche
und praxis
pabst franziskus feiert die
ostergottesdienste wie schon im
vergangenen jahr wegen corona nur mit
wenigen gläubigen der petersplatz bleibt
leer
die ostermesse mit den segen urbi et
orbi der stadt und dem erdkreis findet
im petersdom statt
und das wetter in dieser karwoche wird
hierzulande frühlingshaft mild bevor es
dann ab gründonnerstag wieder kühler
wird der montag startet mit viel sonne
im südwesten bleibt es den ganzen tag
wolkenlos nur im norden halten sich
dichtere wolken bei 12 bis 22 grad
dienstag und mittwoch wird es dann
überall sonnig und deutlich wärmer am
mittwoch bis 26 grad
ab donnerstag wird es mit etwas regen
deutlich kühler vor allem im norden
und eines wird wie immer nächste woche
die redaktion journal und journal update
wird sich den ganzen tag darüber
streiten und darum kümmern was am abend
in eine halbe stunde nachrichten gehört
und was nicht
christian sievers und kaiser richter
bringen das ergebnis dann hier über die
rampe eine gute woche hinein
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]